You recommended that I not take vitamin C supplement that I was taking is IV vitamin C ever useful
So much is said about it online. So
Do it more details on why I would say not to take a vitamin C supplement to a cancer patient look at the
blog post that's titled
Heartic state oxidative stress to kill cancer. You start typing heartic state in our website
Search or you know, it'll come up and you'll see that article
Vitamin C at the dose that you would be able to take orally is going to be in an antioxidant
Vitamin C at a dose that you would
Injected to your veins in the NIV is going to be oxidative
So that's the difference. So you're looking for an oxidative here
For cancer, you don't want an antioxidant because you would be negating everything else you're doing. So you don't want to take oral vitamin C
But could you do IV vitamin C? Well, you could sure if you want to you could do IV vitamin C
There's no negative tips of that. I guess
There are some negative. So the only negative would be if you're doing if you're if you're if you're if you're if you're doing
If you're doing chemotherapy and you're getting a port put in then
There's really no negatives to doing
IV vitamin C through the port
Because the the negative to doing IV vitamin C is is I the vitamin C can burn your partner can burn your vessels
So that can be a negative for some people if they're getting IVs in their arm
It can burn their vessels over time and it can be it's not gonna be tarp or you're no heal, but it can be a
strong irritant
But if a person has a port because they're doing
T-bo that it's really easy to do it through the port that you don't get you don't have that negative
There really isn't any other negatives to find be vitamin C
So it's it it fits with any other therapy
You could do IV vitamin C if you're doing chemo. We could do IV vitamin C if you're doing immunotherapy
You could do IV vitamin C with any of the therapies that we have as well. It's an oxidative therapy and
There's really no other downsides to it